could the covered wave be nearing a peak
already well perhaps the latest data
from the office for National statistics
suggests just over 2 million people were
infected in the weekend in the 10th of
October that's one in 30 and a rise of
just over 15 on the week before but
there is a lag in this data and other
sources which are more up to date though
knowledge comprehensive suggests the
spread of the virus may be slowing
remember the daily dashboard nowhere
near as many people test these days so
it's no good for judging covered rates
but it's useful for tracking the trend
and it does seem to be leveling off
that's backed up by figures from the UK
Health Security Agency rates in hospital
patients and staff are down to 11 in 100
000 from just under 14 the week before
it suggests rates are coming down in the
wider Community too now if that trend is
firmed up by more data in the next week
or so it will come as a relief for the
NHS but hospitals are still facing a
serious surge of flu rates are up in
every age group according to the latest
data but there has been a particularly
sharp rise in children aged between 5
and 14. it's now about 11 and the UK
Health security agency has warned of an
increase in more severe illness in even
younger children these are
hospitalization rates and they're up in
every age group but admissions are the
highest by far in children age four and
under it's the same story in intensive
care units admissions are up across the
board but rates again are highest in
children age four and under doctors are
urging parents to take up the offer of
flu Jabs for their children so far
between 12 and 13 of two and three year
olds have been vaccinated but that's
well down on the same time last year
normally it's older adults who are most
likely to develop serious flu but
younger children are unlikely to have
any immunity to the virus because flu
rates have been negligible during the
covered shutdowns so what we're seeing
could be another hangover from the
pandemic